greetings from podcast Ville the church
is brought to you by there's a buzzy
gift on everybody's list this year it's
something they'll use twice everyday it
was featured on Oprah's old list and
it's perfect for everyone with a mouth
no this is a gift of quip an electric
toothbrush design to make brushing
better let me tell you something they
sent me to or me and my wife too hooked
on them and as far as one on the road
with him they're easy they only need one
plug in they'd stay charged this is the
future do you understand me
if you're into this type of a clean
mouth or whatever the hell you want to
do with the sonic vibration is gentle
enough on your sensitive gums and a
built-in timer with guiding pulses to
remind you when to switch sides
that's a toothbrush so see why I love
quip and why you might think quip is a
good gift that's why I love quip that's
why they have over 5000 verified
five-star reviews [ __ ] looks like a
big-ticket gift with the stocking
stuffer stuff a price starting at just
$25 and if you go to get quick calm
right now you'll get your first refill
pack for free free with the quick polite
your toothbrush but you don't have to
tell you gift e that that's your first
refill pick pack free I get quick calm /
Joey number 2
listen 2019 is coming you want to start
the year you get a little older you
don't get no younger Robin Hood is an
invest in that that lets you buy and
sell stocks EFT s is EF ETFs is options
and kryptos all commission free the
Jamie or the mission free they strive to
make Financial Services work for
everybody not just the wealthy for guys
like you and me not intimidating way for
the stock market newcomers to invest for
the first time with true confidence
simple and intuitive clear design with a
data presented and easy to digest way
I'll tell you what my wife's been using
it and she loves it be app it's nice and
easy
but the most important thing about this
Robin that it that there's no
Commission for he's okay other
brokerages charge up to ten dollars with
Robin Hood
it's gratis Robin Hood is giving the
church family a way to start 2019 on the
right foot
they're gonna give you a free stock like
Apple Ford or sprint to help you build
your portfolio sign up at church Robin
Hood calm again
that's church dot Robin Hood calm this
is the way to start the new 2019 we take
that [ __ ] meal who do the
[ __ ] sugar Monica
oh please Whitney Cummings tremendous
why does that touch my heart this is
sometimes I put this [ __ ] on it sounds
outdated the doors but yo I classic it's
[ __ ] classy that song were to be
released today be the number one hit for
two years I think so really don't you
think it was a new artist yeah somebody
redid it really uh the guy that did the
5450 tour in the 80s redid it not as
good you know I like he sings he always
sings about booze don't [ __ ] matter
Johnny Cash no George burger joy I've
been the destroyers we did it but not it
wasn't no [ __ ] Jim Morrison [ __ ] Jim
Morrison took it to a different level
Whitney Cummings
a pleasure you're like the Jim Morrison
of calm I'm [ __ ] waiting here for
seven years I'm wait-listed quarterly
[ __ ] the singer fingers arose in
November rain I always want to do your
show I'm too intimidated by you know and
we just didn't know we're both simulated
by that's so weird that can't be true
first of all you know I get very
intimidated by someone he would bring
you up and you be like I don't want to
bother at the store
the only modern people you know some
some women have and I didn't it wasn't
an air of bitchiness of nothing it was
just an air of I'm Whitney [ __ ]
Cummings and I respected that
that's super kind I do have this too
like before I go on I'm not that social
like I'm kind of like super
focus and I'm trying to get a vibe of
the crap like I'm not great at
socializing at the Comedy Store until
after my set and I think a lot of people
think that I'm like a [ __ ] or like
aloof and it's not I'm just like
insecure and I'm trying to like try out
new [ __ ] and you know in the Comedy
Store has gotten super like popping
lately and it's there's like agents in
there and pretty I just get nervous
here's the deal
you go that great Paul Mooney once told
me to be an entertainer you have to be
entertained so Tuesday nights what I do
is if my spots at 10:30 yeah I like to
go into Sam's room and make some extra
money or whatever in there but I'll tell
you what's fun you know what's fun just
smoking a half a doob maybe not with
quarter of a xanax and sitting Mitzi's
chairs in the back and watch the three
people that are up before you if you did
that on my set I would leave I wouldn't
stop perform I do it all the time Oh
common I went down there to watch you
the other night no no I didn't let you
and then I walked out of the front no
this is why I do flappers this is why I
do little clothes oh I don't like to
learn from you I see what you're doing
you remember unless you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you can learn something every
comment whether at the open mic level
into the highest level an open mic time
it says something that'll go [ __ ] I used
to do that yep yep okay that's right and
a [ __ ] pro like one white will do
something you go [ __ ] I gotta start
doing right so when I watch Ron Wyatt
I'm just like yes of music so you got
you D'Elia
Ali Wong Rogen and then me no okay so I
gotta watch everybody
I watched Ali and I'm sitting back there
going now while I'm watching the Lear
I'm going thank God I don't gotta follow
this [ __ ] cuz that's been slow that's
for me yeah I followed the way it took
me about six months to get the hell yeah
and if there with him you're done I had
to follow you one night I don't think
you remember this oh that's good that's
right
you were killing like the building was
shaking like it was like [ __ ] was
shaking
and uh I think you did a half-hour am I
wrong
22 I think you did more than 15 minutes
and it was just like ah I mean it was
like applause break after setups like
you were killing so hard I was like
looking around I was like anyone I got a
I lied about having a migraine
I do get migrants lie but I was like
just someone in my head starting to hurt
like just thinking about going on after
you and I got up and I was like I can do
this I can [ __ ] handle it and I had
to regroup I just like like barreled
into my material and I tried to just
like channel your momentum and they were
not having it and I had like I need to
go okay guys I know you guys miss Joey
so do I that's just a regroup like I had
to just address it because there was
this like a morning in the room that you
had gotten offstage and I just had to
totally reset the energy sometimes
Sebastien will do that I learned that
I'm super I learned that from Sebastian
when he hired follows like really
high-energy act he'll kind of just pace
around like a like a [ __ ] lion in a
cage for like 30 seconds and just kind
of like get the focus back onto him that
was the original teachings but see sure
really sure for me to punch you in the
face yep and for you to be able to put
your hands up breathe and think about
what your next move is that's why I take
my daughter to bully buster because
every class you get the belt above the
head and it may sort of think well she
belts something in the head and life is
all about getting and belted in the head
and what's your next move
if I belt you in the head and cover your
head you lost a war yeah you know when I
first went to the store it was Dahmer
era that was on fallible yeah
unfollow I mean how would I remember
driving down there like with tears in my
eyes like what am I gonna die and the
black guy would dredge but isn't around
no more he was spotless clean and a
killer hmm he hadn't been around for 25
years he was there from the beginning
admits he was still giving spots at
12:30 and I was have to go from
following him and the original rules to
Dom in the main room so I'm over there
just take two beats and then it takes a
couple months to learn once you go up
then go let's keep it going
for Whitney Cummings isn't she great I
wish I could you died you died I have to
go up there and say let's keep it going
for Whitney Cummings but then without
saying this I gotta go [ __ ] Whitney
Cummings yes uncle Joey time now [ __ ]
yeah and you have to learn how to make
that transition and on and what you're
saying is now clicking for me about
watching the comic before cuz Dom
whenever he goes after a comic I've
noticed he'll kind of do tags on the
jokes before him of the set before and
it kind of like fuses the energy of the
room yeah it's tremendous for the room
and it feels like we're all a team and
it's not like the audience's like up
here's our commercial break you know
like it's just it's not such a hard
pivot and he does it so masterfully like
whenever he follows me he'll do a bunch
of tags on my jokes which I'm like can I
have those and I think it makes it less
like traumatic for the audience
energy was now you're a young woman
you've had great success in LA in a long
time you've been how long 11 years more
than that I think I said a low I feel
like I said five years for like 10 years
so I moved out here in like 2003
straight out of college and just started
writing boom BAM you know I was yes and
no like I think everyone kind of knows
about your successes and nobody
publicizes your failures right no one's
blasting out all the shows that didn't
go or all the scripts that didn't get
made but the first job I got was that
show Punk'd which was that Spiro disease
yeah he was on it yeah yeah yeah he was
on it [ __ ] you
he was the season after me BJ Novak was
on at Dax Shepard I think that's how
that's blew up yeah that first season
and um and but that was paying you know
for after scale once every three weeks
or something you know I wasn't actually
um you know paying my bills or anything
but I remember I would write specs like
I'd write specs for TV shows and I was
like writing scripts but most of them
never got made I mean I wrote like four
pilots that never got made and then my
first real job I got a job writing on
Last Call with Carson Daly like I got a
stand-up spot on there and then they let
me write because I think they just like
needed a girl and then
I always want to write for the roasts
like that was just my dream and I would
like write jokes I would write jokes and
they said like nope they're not hiring
anybody like they have the same group of
dudes that they always have and I just
kept writing jokes and I just wouldn't
take no for an answer and I wrote for
the set the Flavor Flav roasts I want to
say I wrote like 17 pages of jokes for
everyone that I thought might be on the
show Lisa Lampanelli Jeff Ross greg
Giraldo like all the guys that are kind
of normally on it and I sent it in and
there was a joke they really wanted so
they had to hire me for a week and it
was uh it was ended a comic named some
more ended up doing it but the joke was
about Flavor Flav and the joke was a
Flav you look like what Magic Johnson
should look like right now so that was a
joke and they wanted to use it and they
couldn't just hit you know they had to
like hire me for a week which like it
was a formality but I was just like
working my ass off to try to get them to
help me back the next week so I ended up
writing on the roasts and I ended up
doing the row so I think that's kind of
the first thing that I kind of did that
I don't care about you been relentless
relentless
and then I still remember I wasn't going
to the store you were really [ __ ]
smacking people around what and you
produced this stand-up show on Showtime
I can't believe you remember that
okay this is this is this is what I'm
gonna tell you why I remember that
because up to that time yeah I was funny
and I had my moments and whatever but I
was missing something something was
missing from my act to get me to that
next level
huh and your show came out on a Friday
night or something and there was a
particular comic that I'm gonna leave
nameless the house dear friends wit and
he told me was gonna tape your show so I
the show came on you come on welcome to
my show ba ba ba and I gotta take a [ __ ]
but the bathroom was close to the TV so
I'm like she's probably gonna bring up
somebody else before my friend let me
just go and then take this [ __ ] [ __ ]
with the bathroom door open I was
probably taking a [ __ ] out of stage but
my friend thought stay
you brought my friend on stage and I
real and I had been friends with this
person for years and I like to stand up
and moments he made me laugh but he had
the same problem I had that something
was missing and from me listening I
couldn't watch him I hadn't listened to
his set while I was taking his [ __ ] I
said that's it I'm not doing those style
of jokes no more and I became a story
tell from you doing that show had me
listening to the comic and realizing how
bad he really was
I started storytelling this is blowing
my mind this is how crazy this and I'll
tell you after the show I'm the reason
you're the Richard Pryor of our day no
no the reason why while I was taking a
[ __ ] I heard him do the material and I
and I I love I what I what I had the
opportunity to a podcast I loved it and
I did not want it
I did not want music Adam you're so
[ __ ] good I don't want anything to it
I wanted it I want it - I grew up on
how old is your dad he's passed but he
would be 74 for nothing don't think ah
you know when you're 50 we grew up on
listening to albums all those Richard
Pryor that right was it all that should
I have
yep I learned to listen it that vewy
there was no special for that which he
did so I had to bide Bicentennial digger
I had a by was it something I said
I had a by George Carlin live I had a
bond there and listen already couldn't
walk around it wasn't it wasn't out in
the gym it was so be listening to that
guy do those [ __ ] straight dumb type
jokes oh yeah they get a laugh and they
got a laugh in the club you'll be a
feature act for the rest of your life
you'll be a great feature for the rest
of your life you in those things but
knowing you go out stage no one knows
who you are over those who you are
change wipes of that decision from being
that bathroom I wiped my ass and I went
out there watched the rest of the show
and that Monday I started writing a blog
on MySpace I would write a story about
my life misspelling words you're in
you're like I had since college I hadn't
written anything some kaalia on a joke
on a piece of paper and you try but I
hadn't gotten in front of a computer or
they didn't since college so I lost all
my pronunciation and
started writing a blog every Monday no
matter what I did that blog had to be up
about a particular story of my life me
bugging somebody me [ __ ] at that sex
of somebody behind a tree and then
turned me into a story all stuff that
couldn't be one line letting people even
if there's a one night why is it a
one-liner
how this would affect you and how is it
gonna affect the audience by you saying
it this way so this is the reason why
I'm telling you this [ __ ] joke and
this is the reason why you're gonna
[ __ ] believe it and laugh at it and
remember it and let be bonded to me I
wasn't doing that I was doing kind of a
Rodney type thing one liners are great
have you ever seen somebody do one why
there's a 45 minutes I have seen it
holistic and I think you want it but
it's it's hard don't expect anybody
that's handicapped
I love handicapped comics but it's tough
to pay 45 hours 20 minutes here like how
much cheese can I get you know that's
why you got to put them in 20 minutes
shows because that you get all you eat
out and [ __ ] you know no offense to
nobody I'm just telling you the truth
then you know it's like the Chinese guy
with a ping-pong ball I don't want to
see it no more I'm saying all right I'm
just know why I'm not just for them you
don't want the guy that sucks you in and
tells you why I suck three dicks that
night yeah if you own a woman you go up
on stage ago when I sucked three decks I
sucked a great dick I'm impressed with
you you know what if I had a rock a coke
that probably talked to you after the
show but if you told me why you sucked
the three dicks yeah it would make me
feel a lot different so that's what I
did from that from listening to that
comic on your show all my and that was
that and it was like what year was that
that was like must have been if I ate
she doesn't sign seven yes then I eat
because that was like the first thing I
ever produced and I kind of fell into it
in a weird way they wanted me to write
jokes but then I started this the
content like then they're like well you
know comics why don't you just produce
it like I didn't really know what I was
doing you know didn't matter
I really kind of just like booked comics
that I either had their number or I
thought they didn't like me and I wanted
to like give them a job so that they'd
like me more like Ian Edwards I never
knew if he liked me or not and I like
loved him so I was like hey you wonder
why I was like my way of there's like
trying to get like doing mmm yeah or
just like people who I thought that I at
least knew that I knew needed like a TV
set or neat like Chris D'Elia I don't
think he had done a TV set at that point
and him and I were doing like open mics
and doing like long beach bowling alleys
and [ __ ] and I was like I think this
guy's pretty good and then just people
that needed like a tape you know cuz
that back then if you didn't have a tape
you didn't have [ __ ] don't sure you need
a tape remember that you need a
five-minute tape to do the talk shows to
the Letterman and Leno everyone was just
trying to get a tape I'll never send the
tape
yeah I would send blank babes oh that's
amazing
hey sometimes they call me and say yes
that was great but we're not gonna use
you for this segment of [ __ ] like that
wait shut up you know what intentionally
send a blank I would send my names to
everybody the best one was the guy from
Houston Mark matter who called me back
and said your tape was great and he was
a cokehead to half that's how I yell at
him and then years later I heard about
Chelsea sending the tape out with her
[ __ ] on the washer and dryer at the
end that's true I like [ __ ] everybody
I never saw it what was it settin the
Comedy Store
no we sent to different Booker's and it
was sent like as a joke from Chelsea I
heard it was a joke from Chelsea Oh got
it because Chelsea met with five minutes
I heard doing stands right and then her
getting [ __ ] on a washer/dryer
just to see if they wouldn't watch past
that certain point it's a pretty good
that's a pretty good I came back out of
years later and said she put out a sex
tape and she was like no oh she did it
and I remember that now that's why she's
like she totally [ __ ] hate me they
were like yeah that's all she's like hey
dummies guess who sent that out yeah me
me because the guy at The Comedy Store
was one that edited for her and he after
about three weeks he couldn't take it
and he gotta tell somebody
type in Chelsea they tried doing the
five minutes and then [ __ ] at the end
on a washer-dryer so Chelsea just want
to [ __ ] people yeah I thought that's
what it was that's so funny I think you
were you're right you're definitely in
never show they came back at it and said
yeah they tried to unearth some scam
don't try to make they try they even
tried the blackmail did they even try
them like say we have assets he doesn't
give a [ __ ] issues like she gotta tell
Fox
you want that tape naked body from video
Chelsea back then I knew Chelsea I think
you knew her but probably before I did
98 yeah you know before I didn't I mean
I knew her when she got her like right
before she got tortured her and she
[ __ ] hated me ever since
oh no hated me ever since at the black
Club um next to the chicken place in LA
yeah
Stalin Wilshire there's a black Club the
Union Earth oh yeah what happened to
that place yeah it's there I thought the
place that the open mic you have to pick
out of a bucket like all these open
microscope they put in their name there
are a lot of those now but you wait you
know they don't even pick it out yeah
it's a lottery they make you wait to
wait the whole she wait for hours that's
why I try not to do I might get stuck it
going to the fuel the same places cuz
that's brutal
like that improv Olympic does that to
you wait for three hours house does it a
lot of places developing is done it is
how crazy is that the one on Hollywood
is yeah closer to your toes right it is
crazy it was there for that long that
would be like the best real estate in
the city and improv Olympic was paying
that rent next to the Roosevelt yeah
probably because a ripoff high only went
to go to stand up and you'd go at four
o'clock and you'd wait til 10:00 and
probably not even get up it was a [ __ ]
that's why I only did bars I would do
that Westwood brew Co you ever go down
there never in Westwood feels right it
was no oh no Niels is Westside comedy
theater that's now but there was a bar
at Westwood on you UCLA campus we will
go to on Mondays and Thursdays you show
up at 10:00 o'clock and you go on at
like 1:00 a.m. use wait there's a bunch
of drunk college kids like
like just walking out during your sad
singing karaoke next door it was a
nightmare I mean I did [ __ ] holes for a
long time that Lucky Strike bowling
alley this is why I think you and I
never saw each other cuz you were doing
clubs and I was doing like looms I was
doing rooms I was doing like Miyagi's
you remember the sushi restaurant they
just have a room there and they'd have
MTV Jams playing on the TV loud so you
have to scream over the 90s R&B music
now across the street was it still Jay
Davis Dane Cook I miss that dublin's I
never I was never there I came right
after don't let me tell you something
you can't miss town jerk about your
comedy Kareem you think about like those
nights I make that right on Laurel
Canyon to the Comedy Store and my heart
stops twenty years ago that was
Christoph when you're apart on Laurel
Canyon right there
it's the sunset that's the [ __ ] mall
in the [ __ ] dragon mega store a mega
store that's a gas crunch if you look to
your right right there that used to be a
rock club huge comedy you need nightclub
that nightclub was an old guitar like
Nirvana
so Mondays Tuesdays and Wednesdays in
like ten comics up between seven and
nine and then the rock bands came on it
oh sure
you went down thirty more yards taquito
whatever across the street there's the
National Lampoon Building yep pinches
tacos
then there's the pinches tacos there was
a bar under they had a union that was
it's called the den now yeah booked by a
Melamed and what's the movie star Tom
Cruise no I used to run a room no amen
dodge ball dodge ball amen well Farrell
no no when they when they hit that movie
in 98 what's that movie him and Jon
Favreau and the other [ __ ] swingers
were they - yeah they were all doing
they all live together
so I met I met a Vince Vaughn Live
Together so I met I met invincible and
put together a room at the Union they
would go then Vince Vaughn broke up with
his girlfriend and she stayed in the
apartment with
I met I met pretty girl great girl and
they would run the room together that
became a [ __ ] drug comedy Nick
DiPaolo
Paulie show me that was like because
Tuesday night was now all black man at
the Comedy Store right so well the
original room would only get eight white
people
so wait tripping Tuesdays has been going
on is that that's what we're his trip
and Tuesdays taught is that Comedy Store
urbanite that was that's but that was
something else that I called that was
the brothers the two brothers from st.
Louis that the one guy did American X
and the other guy did Oh Jackson Jackson
moved the Michael Jackson the the Janet
Jackson movie Joe Torre that's right
well that's crazy
that place is sold out every for I
remember when I first can't like you
have these little photographs in your
minds that are just emblazoned in your
brain and one of them was Tori like I
remember going to calm me store I
remember the first time I went on the
stage and you know Letterman is written
in lights right yeah coughs Smirnoff I
never knew what that even I didn't even
know you know she's like yeah go and
those were burned into my brain as I was
bombing as an open mic her because I
would go every Sunday and Monday to the
comedy store open mic and Doc would help
me out you know and I remember going up
there but Joe Torre that's one of them
all so crazy Cindy crazy sick Argus and
then the Union fizzled out and Jay
Davies moved in there with the big it
had been cooking area but across the
street on Tuesday nights was danger Wow
the Yogi's was pure danger because every
cop in that sushi you're in a lot of
days yes every comment found that they
give you free sushi if you do this set
10 p.m. Tuesday sushi is I don't
recommend ma it was all those savages
mm-hm
but I still remember being at Jay Davis
Israel Dublin's and getting the call
from my ex stripper girlfriend going
where are you I might um
Dublin's and she's like come across the
street you're not gonna believe this
it was Whitney Houston singing I will
always love you Bobby Brown was in the
audience and then was she got off [ __ ]
got up onstage hit me baby one more nice
piers he Spears at me I at me Aggies on
a Tuesday night or you can eat sushi
that's how big a head blown up to like
Tuesday but now next to the pink I know
exactly that - it was two floors
upstairs you got on stage I remember
there was a bridge remember there was a
moat like you had to you had to go up on
stage and there was a little bridge
between you and the audience a little
koi ponds I don't mean it was there was
I meant because I just remember one time
watching Duncan Trussell go up there
with his [ __ ] suitcase no one could
hear any of us and we couldn't tell if
we were all just bombing so hard or if
they actually just couldn't hear us cuz
the audience was so far away and they
were playing MTV Jams like loud and he
just started like insulting people in
the audience saying the most insane [ __ ]
and we were done I mean it was like the
hardest I think one of the hardest that
times I've ever laughed besides Brody
Stephens rating in the New Year like
eight years ago The Comedy Store and
telling people in the audience that he
was gonna ruin their New Year's at 11:45
bunch of couples just sitting there with
balloons hanging just [ __ ] are you
doing New Year's this year Phoenix
Phoenix is fun Phoenix stands up live I
don't think it's stand-up live it's the
new place it's brand-new is it stand up
lie stand up watch 650 I think it's are
you doing the whole weekend or just
leave
it's called see bead if you don't see it
no maybe it's called see beyond Tatum I
don't even know they just booked this
[ __ ] I don't ask a lot of questions but
I think it's the same owner
okay so Phoenix and are you doing the
whole weekend prayin I don't know but
I'm just I'm in Portland
up until New Year's Eve I do Portland in
that I go to Phoenix hitting it I'm
doing Oxnard that
that club is gorgeous I love it I love
it love it away it's perfect box perfect
or perfect cloud perfect I love I love
Ontario I love doing shows around LA
that aren't right in LA how's the [ __ ]
huge and excellent yes it's great I
don't know why it's you know everyone I
eat a bag of dicks you know what I
always there's two people by the cobs do
I go there just a diet slope like
politically correct I gotta go in there
[ __ ] first just [ __ ] first with no
grease Koko mother maybe if you're lucky
I gotta go onstage because like like San
Francisco
yeah the punchline is why get down I get
the punchline is fun you should just do
Palace of Fine Arts you should just do a
theater you get your people you don't
get a bunch always the power supply
those beautiful okay so theater what is
it seven hundred thousand ninety one
thousand seats you do two shows I
haven't done in a while because I did
cop last time I was there I did a full
weekend at cops but yeah you'll do two
shows one night yeah you know seven and
a nine it's beautiful because I think
that kobzar need a lot of walk-ins that
are sort of like hmm you're not allowed
to say that well one we can I call
headlines Laurie I'd bombed into a
little sad Late Late Show
Bob's is a very specific type of bombing
because it's very cavernous oh my god
it's very deep and it's very much like
you can't like there's certain places
like the punch lines if you're eating
[ __ ] you can kind of fix it you can kind
of because you can see the audience but
if you're bombing at Cubs I mean you are
a death oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's like you
know what else every time I'm in there I
always think of fires gonna start I was
thinking a movie Carrie I would love for
blood to come down and drench me that
might get some laughs actually I'd love
to see them light them up again every
time I'm up to I'm like something to
start a fire in the back I don't know
why I was every comedy club I'm
surprised they don't catch on fire every
day no building that looks smells like
arson I know arson when I see it
I know arson when I see it and I could
tell that building has arson written all
you know they built their birth the old
one no everyone interview do do not know
they'd know Pierrot old cops
I'm not joking what do you mean go
online they used to be an old cars I got
lit on fire don't tell me my business
guys like don't tell me my business I
don't say everyone's different Cisco
vapes now nobody smokes I've know all
you need is a little butane
I got Jews that are going to your place
a little butane in their sock and one of
those life is one of those matches they
light off their foot you know off to
show us your business will be in flames
like [ __ ] the communist guerrillas
lit the palace of [ __ ] whatever in
flames and that [ __ ] thing what's
that Marcos you're watching wait so cobs
used to be it burned down a table just
to be somewhere else
in 2002 hold on dog why don't I believe
you on Chestnut Street on in the marina
and then in 2002 and moved to Columbus
Ave top practicing his how did it catch
on fire I don't know what happened
that's [ __ ] crazy well you know
whenever you walk through kitchens at
comedy clubs it's kind of a fun thing to
do you walk through the kitchen you're
just looking around and you're like
fingers crossed we're gonna survive
tonight you know when you go around some
of these older clubs that's like I was
lawyer this weekend I love that Club I
was there what I'm gonna do is that is
the club will go into the week before I
do I'm doing it I'm doing four nights
that the March 20th the week for my
special OSAP always DC are you going
back home yeah yeah I I had you know the
last two specials I taped here because
there's something to be said for like
you do 50 cities and then like you're
doing your special you get on the road
and you're sleeping in a hotel and you
know so I was like let me just sleep in
my own bed so I did that broad theater
in Santa Monica for one and then I did
Irvine Barclay theater out there at
university or universe California Irvine
and then I was like I want to do LA
again I was like you know what it's just
I'm worried LA it it's feeling too much
like an echo chamber and I don't want
this to feel like a liberal elite comedy
special like I want it to work
everywhere I'm going everywhere and then
I just want to shoot it in DC because
there's a little bit of ever
they're like a diverse city this here is
the weirdest town because I do great
there that's why is that weird you do
great and I go hop in that place I love
my CDs I love it I love it there are
secrets in DC there's lies in DC
everyone in DC has like you know it's
like Hollywood but a different business
you know I grew up in DC and it's like
it's it's where as LA is about Fame New
York's about money DC's about power you
go there because you want some kind of
power you want to be involved in the
scene you know it's just a different
kind of Hollywood and it's a lot of it's
a lot of sinister [ __ ] goes on in DC you
know it's a lot of [ __ ] live
there and that's kind of what I like
about it and there's a lot of diversity
this last time I went I had Jon Bernthal
on the show I have you seen a movie
called me Earl and the dying girl no he
is his performance in it is a plus well
I didn't know he was in DC oh I didn't
either
yeah so we were talking I'm like I'm in
DC this week it's like way you gotta go
I'm at the 9:30 club so he went on that
is like you know understand that's like
a religious well Dave Grohl I mean
that's so Henry Rollins I saw Henry
Rollins for the first time when I was 15
years old at the 9:30 club like 9:30
club was like where I saw like MxPx all
these like straightedge bands like it
like 9:30 club is like the Roxy in DC
it's like I was tremendous I'd only do
one show that I could have sold out to I
can't believe you've won was it awesome
awesome I think I'm gonna go back I
think I want to go back you should do
you should I was perfect then the 9:30
club is like one of the top five most
like magical venues in almost history
it's just that every great bands like
rock bands kind of it's like a rite of
passage to play there like so much
history has been made let's go go music
like wait this gogo music is like you
can't not like you just can't like I
don't give up a little bit I don't give
a [ __ ] who you are I don't give a [ __ ]
who you voted for I don't care what your
bodily injuries are when go
comes on you're just like it unites us
and it like no one's like oh this [ __ ]
you know everyone's so opinionated about
music but there's some kind of visceral
it's like it's like you're rolling on e
or something when you hear it like you
can't not smile when it comes on you
know it's just like unites everybody
whereas I feel like now music is like
polarizing people people like oh I like
this band hooked up and you're like
Jesus it's music like when did we get so
angry about music you know Dave Grohl
did that show on HBO and it was um what
was it I think I might be getting the
name wrong but it was like episodes of
like yes
music music in different cities anybody
go to mine on DC a whole thing on 9:30
and my feet you see music scene in the
80s it's [ __ ] awesome it's awesome
and it kind of explains all those your
childhood life I mean obviously awesome
really no I grew up in alcoholic home I
grew up an alcohol calm dad mom and uh
dad gone you know um I don't talk a ton
about my dad because I'm still kind of
processing all of it and I'm still
really like protective of him he was my
hero but you know being a man without
money at that time with kids and
complications you know you got to do a
lot of sketchy [ __ ] you know so I
actually have a lot of admiration for
him whereas when I was younger I was
like my dad lied to me my dad didn't
pick me up from school and his
mistresses picked me up from school and
he did all this [ __ ] up [ __ ] and like
I'm gonna tell stuff program now but
it's like I now know like in my cells
that like he did the best he could and
that being a man during that time and
the way my grandfather raised him like
you know he just didn't have the tools
like men back then weren't like I have
to hug my daughter and tell her how
smart she is like he just didn't learn
that you know and I like that he didn't
raise me as if I was a girl if that
makes any sense he kind of raised me
like I was his son you know we were
playing sports were playing basketball
you know the time I did have with him he
was just like beating the [ __ ] out of me
on the basketball court making sure I
was good you know and like slamming me
with spelling words to make sure I was
gonna do well on the test like he didn't
care if I I liked him he only wanted me
to succeed in life you know he taught me
a work ethic that was like next
I'm the same way with Murphy really I'm
to the point where she's big into
martial arts she's really excelling over
there that's us at the age of five I
mean she excels know it solves that
everything like she's good at the pool
they like her that's good probably don't
coddle her when she doesn't achieve
anything I try to race how my mother
raised me I was raised without a dad for
a few years somewhere mom had to play
both hands so this of the fence and when
you see a woman do that it's really hard
and I respect it like you respect your
dad today
I respect my mother for that smack in
the head when I wouldn't get off the
donkey I may be 16 Broadway the [ __ ]
like that you know like I just so I try
to treat her the same way the other
night she clocked me in the face
my mom smacked me in the face once I
didn't smack her back I just grabbed her
and said you can't do this and I
explained to her why and I gave her a
timeout she was very apologetic and
she's uh she wants to do good yeah she's
good but I'm gonna try to raise her the
same way your dad raised you he would he
would always say to me I don't need you
to like me I'd be like I hate ya and
he's like I don't care he's like I I'm
gonna make it hard in here so it's easy
out there how long ago did he pass two
years year-and-a-half you still think
about him Allah Ya Allah I'll start
crying um yeah it was really [ __ ] up
the story is too horrifying I don't want
to upset anybody yeah yeah but he was a
badass like Duke of Deception warrior
you know and I was he a gangster
he was a what we just call like a white
collar criminal and he loanshark
yeah like we would have like really
expensive paintings in our studio
apartment and you know I got like an
Acura when I turned 16 I like I'd get
collateral to see like I would you know
for Christmas when I was eight I got
like an engagement ring
like all right like you know he was um
and I think at the time I didn't
understand how like magical his
existence was cuz I was so I just wanted
more of his time and I couldn't get it
you know and cuz he was always gone and
he he'd leave for a day
and then I'll be back tomorrow and I
wouldn't see him for like a month and
then he'd come back with you know with
all these incredible stories and gifts
and you know that was confusing for me
and he'd leave me in dangerous
situations and stuff which I think at
the time he didn't understand how
dangerous they were so I'm still at the
place in my life where I'm trying to
delineate like anger around it and
resentment around it and and just
acceptance it like he did the best that
he could
you know um but he was a [ __ ]
and I'm grateful because you have to be
a [ __ ] to survive this world mom
is you know I'm really grateful that she
worked when I was a kid because I saw
how hard you have to work and I'm
grateful for that but yeah I mean she's
I have a lot of addiction in my family a
lot of NSAID you in a 12-step program
yes Allen Anja and this is the one way
you grow up around people that's right
because a lot of times we in a certain
way that's right because you when you
grow up in our alcoholic home you
develop this overdeveloped sense of
responsibility where you think you have
to solve everybody else's problems
because as a kid you're the one making
dinner you're the one handling [ __ ]
you're the one you know going we got to
go to school you're the one like
organizing you know carpool like I just
had to be an adult way too young and you
also get addicted to adrenaline and
excitement you know so even coming out
of the womb like I was already like so
you tend to recreate your childhood
circumstances by seeking out broken
people other addicts chaos adrenaline
stuff like that and then perfectionism
because I had to work so hard to get
attention that the message I got was
like if you're not perfect you're not
worthy of love you know so that's
al-anon it's like you know a lot about
that it's you know they say like in a a
you know whereas addicts that you
substances or alcohol are addicted to
alcohol or cocaine whatever elements are
addicted to people who are addicted to
alcohol or cocaine or whatever fuck-ups
right now I mean just addicted to the
drama of like I'm gonna save you and I'm
gonna fix you know [ __ ] do it
I just love you in less than zero and
it's really it's a martyr complex it
really is we say the 3m really is
mothering martyring micromanaging that
is sort of what we end up
which it's it's own defect like let
people have the dignity of their own
experience it's like you have like a god
complex like you have to rescue
everybody and it's just like obnoxious
so my mother was an alky my mother had a
bar
so how qahal ism was based off her
business she thought like Bert for her
to sell drinks you had to have drinks so
she would get there at 10:00 and start
melt in her mouth
mm-hmm I grew up around her cocaine like
in the 70s in the late 60s I would tell
her why pornos like you're [ __ ]
embarrassing me like I still have being
7 or 8 and going dog why'd you [ __ ]
help sweetie yeah I had it that together
that I could say that happened she would
apologize later on and you know she
doesn't I do it on once in a while I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah just keep your
nose clean yeah you know I grew up with
that it's funny cuz Monday with the
Mercy's school recital at 8:30 in the
[ __ ] morning it was that night that I
got old when I [ __ ] couldn't possibly
in vans was nice yeah I've gotta be up
somewhere and it's her thing and I want
to look nice and [ __ ] all night long
like a guy so I had a pee and I would
get a no pee comes out why am i waking
up why am i waking up before Noby comes
out then you go back then again somehow
you're cold you check your phone and now
you really can't see it yeah it's the
night was funny that I went to her thing
and I got a little high before I went
that morning just as sooner than that my
set I went to the kindergarten with her
and read the book mom while my wife got
the seat so we would have to wait on
line like studio 54 was a huge line so
we got the seat when I was sitting there
watching my daughter it's so funny wait
the our kid when he when they used good
because someday
both Miyagi's all this [ __ ] comes back
to the front of you and that's why I'm
in al-anon cuz I don't want to repeat
the same [ __ ] like all this [ __ ] that so
no no I'm not doing I'm not talking
about that
no no I'm sitting there when she came
out I saw her like go like this when she
saw me a little face just melted and she
just went
why she can't wink with this eye but she
really tried to and she looked at me and
my wife though she didn't even look at
me she doesn't give a [ __ ] but rather
when I thought about one time well it
was my birthday and in those days my mom
would get home you know I was five or
six my mom would get home 3:30 in the
morning from New York out she would wake
up with me trust me get me ready for
school but just in the smell and just a
little look at her I knew that yeah you
know that was as good as it was gonna
get and I never questioned her I liked
walking to school by yourself her being
that how he gave me the independence
that I do understand I do like being
alone ya ain't passed out it - it's
actually kind of convenient for me most
people want their parents to be passed
out although I would go to school
sometimes I come home for lunches she'd
still be passed out and sometimes I come
home at 3:00 and now she'd have the
housecoat on and she was making bets on
the phone and numbers and figuring out
what the score the Mets game was so I
had to buy you know I had a birthday
party it's my [ __ ] birthday I'm in
kindergarten I'm Spanish mmm it's all
white kids nobody really likes me I
don't know what a [ __ ] Cuban is I'll
never forget that I had two o'clock and
you have to know when there was a knock
on the door and there was my mother with
the Puerto Rican was a little Puerto
Ricans body they were both [ __ ] up
already you could see and they came with
two cases of coke and cans and a Carvel
ice cream cake and I became the hero of
the day like I never forgot that about
all the whale the whale birthday all
those first graders a kindergarten went
crazy my mom was the favorite mommy hero
everybody's mother brings kool-aid look
[ __ ] this lady showed up with two cans
and Carvell net yeah two cases of cokes
and cans and whatever and I'll never
forget that moment like that I was good
with my mom left laughs she's never done
anything else ever again
I was good with that several memory I've
heard showing up at two o'clock
hung over his [ __ ] you can already tell
she had a shot of something because in
the morning she would wake up with
Heineken
and tomato juice oh she would do through
three or four lows those what a
breakfast didn't hang and then wherever
the day took her we got to go to the Met
game so let's get going
she'd stop a liquor store like to do
sips all the way off that's but she was
functioning yeah highly highly um you
know and uh and yeah and it's
interesting because I think for me like
you know my family a very good tape like
there was this illusion of affluence you
know like you don't know you're poor
until you go to someone else's house
rate and I mean it but we lived in
Georgetown and DC and it was this like
ostensibly really fancy area but like
then there was the eviction notice and
that like I remember there was you know
I was just haven't thought about this a
long time but when you talked about
school
I carry just like embarrassment with me
all the time you know like I'm like hey
sorry like I always think I've so maybe
my teeth I always think I'm like
embarrassing myself in some way you know
whenever I like say hi to someone or
talk to someone like how did you just
say that oh so stupid you know I just
like beat myself up and I always think
there's some kind of like elaborate like
prank going on it's like a paranoia and
in remind me to tell you my art you
should hear a story about that in a
minute how it like perfectly collided
with this paranoia I have the time he
hid my backpack at the Comedy Store and
I went crazy because I thought that my
worst fear was actually confirmed I'll
tell you about that design but I'm one
time I remember I got pulled out of
class and because the tuition wasn't
paid for the school and they put like a
note on my shirt it was like a safety
pin and it was a little note and it said
like you know a note to my parents
saying you have to pay this and I could
read I guess at that time and I didn't
and it was like a scarlet letter almost
like I wore it around I think it was a
Catholic school as Authority wasn't
enough like shame embarrassment and I
remember like having to wear it or at
like why they and I think about that now
I'm like what is that illegal like I
can't believe a school would do that
like I can't believe it there's a wait
till the end of the day to do it
whatever I'm having to walk around all
day and I was like what's that sign like
oh you didn't pay your tuition you guys
are poor and everyone was just like
making
fun of the fact that I was poor and then
I didn't pay the tuition and I had to go
from school to school because the
tuition wasn't paid and all that but I'm
little things like that they were just
like oh this does a number on a psyche
because I just from them then on was
always so embarrassed but I think on
some level it did make me funny because
I felt like I always had to entertain
kids to make friends you know I always
had to be more entertaining that I was
embarrassing or something I had to like
earn my seat at the table
so I started being funny you know cuz I
think that there was also so much stuff
I had to hide in my family I had to hide
the you know the mess I had to hide the
you know I miss things dad saying and
someone's passed out and this and the
kids haven't eaten and there's no food
in the fridge and I always had to make
up stories and I had to basically lie
like oh no like look at the silly monkey
and like distract people when friends
would come over you know so I think that
being funny very much was like a sort of
device that I developed in order to like
play defense on other people's
perception of what was going on in my
home you know and I also thought I had
to be funny because I thought oh my mom
drinks cuz I'm not interesting and that
like that's I mean as a kid you just
make whatever assumption doesn't accuse
the parent because it's too traumatic on
a psyche to say like my parent is a mess
because then you just feel too unsafe so
you actually just go oh I must suck you
know because you don't want to blame
your parent as such a young child you
just don't know better right so I
remember just going if you're just funny
and entertaining so I used to put on
Jerry Seinfeld records and memorize them
and then go out and do the jokes for my
mom like while she was like doing things
I'd be like hey so Florida eventual left
like I was just go try to do jokes and
make her laugh and like I would put on
costumes and stuff you know I just
thought that that was like oh this will
fix it you know if I can just make her
laugh she won't need to drink this was
the beginnings of your stand-up kind of
yeah the roots of you stand up just pain
this comedy this embarrassment
hmm I mean I think that you know we all
have that pain that then we make it we
make it funny so does this thing as much
halftee that's amazing there you put
that safety pin
I promise to demo this actually so I
just put it together right now it's just
serendipitous that it matches a story
when I was a kid I used to play with
safety pens
we didn't have a lot of like toys and I
played with cosmetics which is kind of
sinister I'd go to like the CVS which
was called people's drunk at the time in
DC and I'd go and I'd like save up money
and I'd go buy like lotion or whatever
cuz I learned from my mom you always
have to look a certain way you know and
and I've compassion for around that
we're kind of in this place in society
where like women aren't supposed to
objectify themselves and whatever like
you know my mother did not learn that
she is from Texas she learned you always
got it like be on point you got to be
glossy you got to have the eye shut you
got to do so
her bathroom was all products you know
so I just learned like it's all about I
was putting like anti-aging cream on
when I was six seven I said I was seven
and I looked for and so I would like
play with my little sort of products and
stuff and I'm yeah that's kind of what I
did it's just it but when my parents
would fight I had these little safety
pins and I would take the I'd open it
and it wasn't like self-mutilation
anything I just sort of pricked myself
just as a weird little way to distract
myself and I always forgot about that
and then I got the tattoo of it like I
was had a surgery and I was on
painkiller and I was like I'm gonna go
get a tattoo of the safety pin I used to
play with it's a kid I thought it was
like a really poignant thing and now I'm
kind of like oh god I always forget that
it's there you're an interesting woman
man really [ __ ] yeah tonight you get you
rocking and rolling who gave you the
right to write the script in the sella
to CBS which one came for his Whitney or
two Broke Girls they were kind of
simultaneous I had written the show for
NBC the Whitney show for Chris D'Elia
and I so we became friends just you are
a cutest couple
in the world are you two [ __ ]
ain't Mary it's a comedy I fight if I
was you I married alia just to call up
Brad Pitt's ex-wife and call her a dirty
[ __ ] not me take a look at me Chris
D'Elia not for I mean you have Brad
meanwhile Brad was [ __ ] other people
so you had newsman Jelena so go [ __ ]
yourself just hang up
I think I think so much of why Chris and
I love each other so much is that we
haven't dated you know that sometimes
brings out the worst in people I think
it brings out the worst in me because I
get insecure I get fearful I could you
know so I think so much of the like our
relationship has to do with the fact
that we didn't like soil it with that
messy [ __ ] you know and get like a bunch
of like feelings involved but I just we
had such a good time together and I just
I wanted to write a show about you know
a couple that have been together for a
while and kind of a gender reversal like
there was a lot of this like on TV every
[ __ ] female character like was
obsessed with getting married and I was
like I are these people like who writes
these character you know like it's just
not my experience you know I saw seven
divorces by the time I was 12 years old
I heard people screaming and vases
flying and [ __ ] and I was just like why
would anyone want to get divorced like I
was very I mean marry
I was very repelled by the idea so I
kept having relationships fail because
I'd be like I don't I get married I'd
love to stay with you but I'm not
signing anything and so I just saw that
marriage caused a lot of problems that
was like a really big message that I got
as a kid like the blueprint and I wanted
to write a show about it and about how
the guy did want to get married he came
from a healthy environment and she came
from a really you know twisted sick
environment and like how to make that
work and can you love each other
unconditionally and also I'm just in
general obsessed with opposites like the
idea of can you love someone that voted
differently than you you know I feel
like when I watch the news today I worry
the answer's no like we're in this place
where like if you don't agree with
someone on everything
he came and be in the same room together
which that's not healthy a son we've got
into a pretty [ __ ] up place I think so
but if I love you I don't give a [ __ ] of
you voted for Hitler yeah if I love you
you voted for Hitler I love it it was
just picturing Hitler running for office
you imagine no I think so I think he
would come made a comeback
come on like this piece [ __ ] the
whole thing Democrats right yeah baby
anyway so it was about that and it was
also like I missed I grew up on sitcoms
like my sitcoms raised me you know
television was my parent growing up and
that's good on some level about on other
levels I guess the messaging I got but
um I really wanted I miss that like
shows had these little like human
moments you know like I love to show
Matt about you and I loved how the whole
episode would just be about like you
know you put the spoon on the hardwood
and you should have put it on the napkin
you know just and what that brings out
in people something tiny and every show
I'm watching it's like the White House
is on fire
like all the plots for every show had to
be so big and it just didn't feel
relatable and I just missed that kind of
like everyday pedestrian humor and how
Universal that is right so I just wanted
to write a show that's about a couple
just navigating little stuff like that
and I wrote it for me and Chris I gave
him a copy of it he didn't even read it
did not read it he's like oh well go to
it I'll go to it this is by the way
before [ __ ] Instagram he had time to
read it like he we were maybe on MySpace
there's only but he like wouldn't read
away like didn't really you know how
many times do you get a script from a
comic where you're just like the blank
potato Chelsea mitten yeah and uh and
then it got picked up by NBC and I had
to audition with a bunch of actors that
were like this tall that looked 15 I
look like a giant pedophile like it was
like they made me audition a bunch of
people and I kept going like you know I
really want Chris I really want Chris
and he came in I'll never forget it I
was like this is the guy because we
couldn't find a guy that was like alpha
enough for me like I instantly just
seemed like there aren't like whenever a
male actor in LA would walk in you know
cuz they're all shaved everywhere and
just but you know like all of it the
hairline and the pans like everyone's in
tanning and [ __ ] and it just it felt
weird and so real like we got to find an
actor who would actually look like he
could I didn't want to be like the top
you know I mean someone that where I was
the beta that could actually like put me
in my place and we were having a hard
time finding X I didn't want to be like
cutting anyone's balls off it's not a
good look you know
I don't want to come off like shrill and
aggressive and annoying and Chris came I
was like this guy's so alpha he's like
you know no disrespect when Chris was
married I think but it was still like he
girls were just like go nuts from
hammering and like he's got swagger and
he's kind of silent and you know tall
dark and handsome
I was like he's the guy he comes in in
neon pink converse sneakers yeah like
the guy that I just told everyone
straight as an arrow alpha male he's
like this is gonna be perfect now it's
like a [ __ ] like the high-top ones they
almost look like little leggings like
little Robin Hood men in tights like
they're all up on his ankle and [ __ ] but
he of course killed it and you know made
it happen but um but that was and then
Michael Patrick King who wrote Sex in
the City was looking for someone to make
a sitcom with and he was talking about
you know cuz he started as a stand-up
actually he used to go on the road with
Tommy rera
Michael Patrick King he has the most
amazing stories about how one night
Donna rera cuz you know he didn't have
any money for food or anything in one
night Don Moreira slid some spaghetti
under his hotel room door like her like
through his door but there was no fork
like this little thing of spaghetti like
somewhere outside Philly where they were
touring and you just sit there and eat
spaghetti with his hands but it was
until the nicest fork
there's no four okay yeah and in anyway
and then he was and I went in and I mean
Michael Patrick King was like you know I
mean he did sexiest city which you know
from me was just kind of a big deal
because I like I really enjoy I learned
very early on that women should be
competitive with women that's right
learned I think that's what happens when
you have a dad who cheats and you see a
mom who's freaking out and who's that
and that uh and sex and City was
therapeutic for me because it just it
was just showed me women getting along
and I like I just needed to see that
because I had a sister and we didn't get
it you know my mom I like it just was
tricky so it was just sarah peuta for me
in a lot of ways and anyway so he was
taking all these meetings I went in I
had like $600 I went to Neiman Marcus
in Beverly Hills and I bought a pair of
Christian Louboutin shoes because he had
done sex in the city
you know the show with all the fancy
clothes and the fancy shoes so I went
you know Louboutins the red bottoms are
very important I went and bought a pair
of Christian Louboutins I drove to the
Warner Brothers parking lot and they
were in the car next to me and I am put
them on but I put tape on the bottoms so
that the red wouldn't because I wasn't
gonna return them yeah I was just I just
bought them just for the meeting and
then I'd go on to the meeting I go to
the bathroom I take the tape off we sit
down you know I crossed my legs so he
can see the red bottle you know so I'm
trying to impress them and I don't know
why I thought that would get me a
writing job I just so badly didn't want
him to know how broke I was you know I
wanted him to think that I was like
successful in making it or whatever yeah
and then we had the meeting you know
it's interesting I I wasn't prepared for
how funny he was because you know we're
comics like I was like I'm gonna kill
this meeting and then he was like really
quick and funny and I was like oh [ __ ]
like it kind of threw me off I didn't
know he was a comic you know and so I
was sort of thrown off by the fact that
he was funny and it was like almost like
this Penn & Teller situation hard to go
[ __ ] like I just wasn't talking because
I was panicked and then I pitched a
couple things that I think he liked and
on the way out I knew I had bombed the
meeting and I I closed the door and then
I popped back in and I said to him hey I
know you're not gonna give me this job
but just please have me at the table
read and I'll punch up the script and I
closed the door and that was it and then
I went and I took the shoes off and it
walked barefoot to my car and I went to
Neiman Marcus to return the shoes for
that I needed that six hundred bucks
back and then he asked for a second
meeting and I was really prepared the
second time and he gave me the job and
he's like I knew you had to have the job
when you said to me I know you're not
going to give me the job but just have
me come in and do punch up on it he's
like I knew you had just the perfect
Leeloo amount of self-esteem to where
you would be funny and be able to do
this I thought you were creators yeah we
created together I thought you had based
it off of your experiences both of us
yeah both of us yeah it was both of us
so the kat dennings character cat is
very much kind of my background and his
too you know like we could have made
these two care
like morph them based on her back
because him and I are very similar he
grew up you know very similar than I did
you know so similarly then I did and I
uh and yeah we've created these two
characters and sort of built the show
and I think people responded to it
because it was about money it wasn't two
girls being like did he call me back we
need to get makeover it's like man it
was two girls like how are we gonna pay
our taxes we don't have this money how
are we need our teeth fixed we don't
have health insurance you know it was it
was watched a couple episodes right I
mean look it's I thought it was about
you I thought it was very sudden
biographical I thought in my mind I'm
like Whitney must have been a waitress
in New York I didn't either I didn't
know about it ya know I had I mean a lot
of that is I mean it was like so many
the stories cuz when I first moved out
to LA I had you know no money so funny
the other day I was on a TV set and one
of the sound guys said that he had used
to work at pink dot and he's like yeah I
used to work a pink dot and I was like
oh god you know so much about me and
he's like yeah I do because I used to go
into pink down on sunset which is right
next the economy store I lived right up
on Miller Drive before I even got spots
at the Comedy Store I would just drive
around because I wanted to live near the
Comedy Store because I was like I want
to be able to walk there every night and
so I before I might even before I ever
did stand-up and I got a apartment right
up Miller Drive you know you go lost yet
again so it set right up there got an
apartment right there and so I would go
to pink dot every night and I had like
$15 usually I was hovering about like
$15 for a couple years now we're going
to pink dot and I would buy Oberto
turkey jerky because you could eat it
for a couple days you know when you sort
of had this illusion that you're
actually eating when you're not and it
got so gross that I started buying maple
syrup and putting maple syrup on it and
so I would every three days go to pink
dot and I would buy Oberto turkey jerky
I can't believe I'm telling you this and
maple syrup and the guy would just feel
like I mean looking as I was just like
do you need help like we should we call
like child services that like we should
we think do a food drive for you and I
would see the sort of pain in his face
about it and I would get like protein
bars you know like I would show up with
like quarters and I feel like how many
can I get a and I have to pull something
away you know I'd say like can I get two
of these and I didn't have enough
okay I guess just one of these and he
used to watch it and he like gave me
this huge hug like this was like three
weeks ago it's crazy how you that those
struggles you'll never have a forget
manner like I still remember living
across from not Cibo Chi bone sunset
point setting down more down two blocks
what's the Brazilian place I love us no
wallahs if you stay on sunset you also
nova bossa nova i used to live across
the street from boston oh you went down
no and I remember waking up there broke
yeah waking up I loved from the store
bro Oh to get up brush my teeth take a
shower where's the store paying $15 by
five not in the spot you household
Mexican rooms mm-hmm Felipe's bars are
holding oh yeah yeah yeah rooms all over
so you could do two rooms picking one
buck 25 yeah yeah 46 to here but I still
remember walking on sunset across room
what's the big big big Israeli
restaurant I rollin a roll aroma I love
that place across and aroma was a gas
station his name was like Jaime and
Jaime was a one-man operation he would
come on check your oil and pump
so although we stand by the shadows and
I would always wait for him to go out
and pump gas and I'd run and stick my
hand my in account and take a pack of
cigarettes whatever they were
withdrawals yeah
menthol whatever the [ __ ] it was that
was my shot now maybe if I got lucky I
could take more Barolo and I would take
a soda and a bag of like what were you
talking about the NA those onion things
I needed funding to onions are good
those are my breakfast yeah that was it
walking on Sunset and I go to Joshua
south and hopefully he would make turkey
burgers he used to buy frozen turkey
burgers and I go over there for lunch
help him do dishes watch the kids
and we eat frozen [ __ ] turkey burgers
if I got any money at all I would go to
Wendy's oh and they had the dollar menu
yeah and I would get to Chile and
the baby Julia that was little to em
the cheeseburger and the chili but
that's what I that's that's there were
all stories that we ended up putting in
2 broke girls like when I first moved
out here I start doing focus group
testing you know they say hey for $50
you show up and you to us tell us what
you think of this night cream whatever I
remember I would do him for like
Neutrogena like they send you the
product like a week in advance and you
use it for like a week and then you show
up and they give you cash you know so
it's it's think about the kind of person
who's showing up for cash 50 bucks you
know it's me and a buncha like meth
heads so you know it's people that need
cash like they don't want to check they
might name a bank account and I don't
ever have a bank account because I would
get those overcharged fees so I couldn't
cuz I kept getting [ __ ] on those you
know you have $7 you do an overcharge
and then if they charge you 50 bucks or
something so I would just keep cash in
an envelope I remember and and I go to
those focus groups and one time I was
doing one and I guess I just like I
wanted to do a good job you know like I
was the door like and it was like a face
scrub like machine you know that you
scrub your face with it I was like
because I was getting like free [ __ ] it
on top of it and I remembering the focus
group one day and they're like so what
everyone think it almost like we loved
it we loved it
great you know can we get our cash I was
like you know I feel like if the if the
handle was like I was like actually
trying to like do a good job and
everyone would just feel like dispatch
like everyone hated me because I
actually would everyone just want to get
their cash and get the [ __ ] out of there
you know so I would do that I would do
like clinical trials I used to do
Buffalo Exchange you know the store
Buffalo Exchange you go you take your
clothes and you try to sell them you
know you can get you know sometimes so I
haven't sold my eggs I did with chick
who sold her eggs she had a little crazy
I was thinking about it why Katie Dixon
yeah restrainer for selling her eggs
yeah she went crazy cuz they put it on
some she was a waitress because the
hormone change she was a waitress at the
Laugh Factory oh and she was very nice
but she was a fan of The Comedy Store so
I'll never forget I had like I never
liked how she was a young girl and I you
were just she would come for the Comedy
Store
don't get good money for your eggs we
would just talk to her at the store and
she liked doing drugs she smoked pot
so one night she came to the store and
she's like who has an 8-ball up and this
[ __ ] I'm like what are you
talking about cuz he doesn't want to buy
label I go hold on Chewie seller an
Eightball and I go why'd you get the - I
hit that jackpot I've been selling my
eggs and all this [ __ ] there's a ball
eggs hate balling so we went over to
[ __ ] in that hotel across the street
from the rouse mm-hmm this is what it
was okay central I know now it's like a
vegan place or the pink dots get a case
of being up and run over there she paid
for the hotel my I make three of us
stayed up all night doing coke but she
kept telling us how she would sell her
eggs and they were given of this and but
then she didn't stop
I guess she's supposed to stop selling
your eggs you do them once or twice I
don't know exactly yeah they get crazy
on the one shop right and the hormone
shots put her over the [ __ ] top by
schandle up robbing the Laugh Factory
she escaped with a comic you know she
got knocked up and she hugged him oh and
they left him tied up in the room so I'm
not kidding you I wish I was kidding I
forgot over the comic was this chick
disappeared I don't like her I like I
just came around like a month later
asking questions about it she went
that's pretty badass the [ __ ] rails
she's still around no I haven't this is
2003-2004 people do weird [ __ ] here like
I let I just love the idea of these
waitresses or managers there's people
that around for two years you know 10 15
years ago who saw the most epic [ __ ] who
are like now you know in Bakersfield
married have a normal life and you're
like you know [ __ ] that would just be
like a number one best-selling book but
they're just living normal lives
somewhere else you know people that get
in comedy and then they get out did you
ever walk through the comedy store like
I was just thinking about this year if
you walk up to the karma store if you go
up to mid Caesar office before you get
the Mitzi's office there's an office and
that office used to be her accountant
and supposedly when he quit he had a
tell our story
Mitsy and the shores had to pay him down
something we I don't know the whole I
forget the guys name I brought up to
something like yeah where is that why
she he had like Harvey Weinstein type
[ __ ] when the store like wherever you if
you're listening sir we your welcome on
the podcast anytime are we know this
accountant guy oh yeah I think he died
there was a couple guys that were given
her trouble the guy that ran la jolla
went on there for a long time he boards
the end he did some interview and once
she started getting paranoid like that
she started I see some people then he
got ice for writing the books and they
pay them off and he died then his wife
showed up with the book and they had to
pay the wife something weird I don't
know all the [ __ ] story none listen
just tell all storm at the peak you know
it's funny when you meet people on the
road they're like I lived in LA for
three years right you're like what did
you do all that I was met his assistant
for in you're like no I bumped into
somebody who was suddenly bigs assistant
on the show I'm not their assistant like
that well he worked on the show and I
bumped into him this year in Kansas City
and he was like I [ __ ] hate it if I
ever see that guy again I will [ __ ] them
you know because you think that now what
you did at that age
yeah you'd think about what [ __ ] you
took from people at that age like the
first ten years I was here I kept my
mouth shut
pretty much kept my mouth shut I didn't
say [ __ ] if I went to a set and you said
something to me even though it's a
little bit offensive I would brush it
off like and then once I stopped doing
drugs I said before I was a comic I'm a
man so you got like a man and I wanted a
set one night to do a Hardee's
commercial Hardee's calls joining
commercial and we had a shoot in [ __ ]
Long Beach and it was a SUV and it was
two mafia guys we pull over when we go
to [ __ ] see the guy that guy's
already been shot he hasn't been shot he
just ate an Arby's [ __ ] calls Junia
chicken
Parmesan sandwich which will kill you
anyway well just come right of your ass
and we bit into it the blood of his
shirt so we get to the car he just nuts
so the other guy says to me on the end
telling either then knowing there we go
we get the [ __ ] out that was the
commercial so we had a shoot in Long
Beach and that was the first time ever
that I came back into being myself when
I realized that I had been in a lie too
long it doesn't really matter what comes
out of your mouth as long as you're a
great comic but stick to your guns stick
to your guns show people because we live
in the town that if you do open your
mouth they say you're trouble to work
with if you say excuse me excuse me I
grew up in New York and nobody would use
this word you can could use this to go
though usually as it's written yeah
that's a period not a comma I'm not
using it I'm doing this way and then
they'll stop and say your problem to
work with no I'm just giving you the
best I can
yeah are you from New York [ __ ] no
you're from [ __ ] Kentucky that's I'm
born and raised in New York what the
[ __ ] you talk about this is the word
when I did the Luis Guzman project me
and the director almost had blows over a
word that I said with Mexicans Puerto
Ricans don't use that word it's also
like I'm helping you I'm help you're
gonna get credit for this thing I'm
doing why would you want yeah I kept
sorry called amigo amigo that's a
Mexican were like yeah Porto Ricans have
150 she don't say amigo I mean Doug
right the next day I got there they Luis
Guzman and the director and like the EP
were like I hate yesterday you would
trouble something to work with I don't
know I just recommend to a line the same
way I did it the audition yeah the line
I said that you stole from me and put it
on yourself because I want the audition
improvise yeah yeah I'm stolen I figured
I'd use the line and I know what it's
ended with that don't bring it up no
more like okay at the pilot chute
I still didn't say amigo you don't mean
though you got the wrong [ __ ] I
said the word I thought it was supposed
to be with like premium smell like a
power play after the show the director
came up to me and looked me in the face
and he's like you know what I'm slated
to shoot three pilots at Fox next [ __ ]
if I see a headshot I'll rip them all up
and I looked at him like oh [ __ ] like I
didn't say it
guess what the show got picked up and
they got fired they got taken down at
the four episodes cos Fox has no time
for that [ __ ] and three nights later who
do I see at the comedy store but the
director and when he saw me he just
stopped in his tracks look through my go
if you would've used the word I told you
you show the stomach on TV [ __ ] and
he just froze and look at me and just
eyeballed me fly away until the original
so it's like the only people I trust are
coming like when I have comics come into
shows I'm like just let him do comics
know it's like you cannot yes some
people have bad behavior that's not what
that was like like we're in the field
we're doing the field research for you
we're making your life easier like let
us come in and tell you what works and
what doesn't like like we have that gut
instinct you know like the best have you
ever seen anything like that have you
ever seen anybody who goes this is the
line but do what you do literally he's
the most huh and he's like I hired you
here cuz I think you're the best person
yeah I'm now gonna leave you alone don't
let you shine I've never seen anything
like that you like this guy nobody works
harder than this guy we did a movie in
New Mexico one of his Netflix movies he
was in a native of Santa Fe I think so
how great was that Hotel san affect yeah
that one that with the pool in the
middle it's like our resort a resort
yeah gorgeous gorgeous the air is like
foods amazing I'm with Schwartz in and
it's just a blast and so uh we're on set
Adam is the star of the movie he's at a
Native American Indian cost at the Hat
the thing the whole thing and he's like
running around placing extras he's he's
reading the script for his next movie
he's like pitching jokes like I i I've
never seen anything like it nothing like
anything he gives you three options and
if your joke Mason that's the joke they
going yeah with me no ego I wouldn't
that after the third week I finally
stopped looking at the scenes because it
didn't really matter
and then we would we do the scene yeah
and then if it wasn't he'd go oh let's
just change it what do you think you
have a joke there like do you want let's
do it like it was just the most fun
collaborative it was like doing you know
just a little [ __ ] web video like
[ __ ] around and they're like oh
millions of people are gonna watch this
like hee hee hee hee it's not it doesn't
feel like a big production with a bunch
of pressure there's no executives around
it's like all his friends yeah that's
why he shoots out he shoots out for the
first six or seven mm-hmm so he gets a
grip going that comes back for three or
four yeah why people show up yeah he's
nice to him oh it was Lovitz and and and
Schneider and all his friends that's the
easiest way to do it that's right move
the most loyal that's great I did a
locker room scene with him when I was I
was 400 pounds and I'm said been on my
man my favorite baseball my favorite one
of my favorite movies is Major League
yeah cube again a major league war jock
listen what if I would wear a jock these
two white kids from Syracuse you know
with suits on VP's of entertainment
somewhere no I haven't and they do too
like and Adams like hold on what's up
Joe heck no listen for this locker room
scene where fun I don't want to wear
thong like Serrano did major league he's
like hold on the people like he can't
the ratings it's no he won't because it
was either are rated PG what it's saying
no I can't see it was the r-rated I
think it'd be 18 so they were like we
don't know if you could leave your dick
I'm gonna leave my dick god I'm just a
jockstrap I'm fat [ __ ] with a jockstrap
and they kept yelling at Adam and
Bernardi but executive producers name
was Michael Bernardi and they kept
saying well this is right and I had him
look at me straight in the face and he
goes go for it and then I quit and I and
this one I do I made the [ __ ] guys
come around me they took my clothes off
right in front of everybody in the
locker will put the jock on balls ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't love me even more for
that even that's the madness great can I
tell you I haven't had a dog bite my ear
off
it's like two years ago came off hanging
down had to get it sewn back on I go to
like a Hollywood it was like some
Hollywood party like I couldn't not go
and I had I still had the injury I still
had it wrapped and it was whole thing
and I had like a Santa hat on I just
showed up in a Santa hat like no one
will know like no big deal and someone
there knew and made like a scene of it
like Whitney got her ear bitten off by a
dog you know and I was like gosh so
saying everybody at the party like knew
about they call they said Hollywood
people and I'm talking about it and I'm
on painkillers and this whole thing and
I actually end up leaving the party kind
of early cuz I was embarrassed it's
weird I find like as a comic like when
I'm on stage I'm super comfortable with
attention obviously but at social events
like I'm not great I get awkward and I
don't want a lot of it if I'm not doing
stand-up I actually don't love attention
I get weird and uncomfortable and I
don't like being the center of attention
if I don't have something to offer back
I just get confused and anyway so I left
the party the next day I mean there were
maybe 200 people to party they probably
all knew about it I get an email from
Adam Sandler hey are you okay so
anything I can do how's your ear like he
didn't have to do that you know like he
saw through the bit I'm like oh it's
fine and I was like sort of trying to
minimize that in making jokes and stuff
and he like sends me an email the next
day to ask me if he can do anything like
it was just it meant so much to me it
was just such a human thing to do he's
uh he's a different dude I still get a
Christmas card from them like why do I
don't get invited to the Christmas
parties no more because I caused habit
one year the one with ice skating what
did you do do people know I mean for
your listener this is a party that is
like it's like when I first moved to LA
it was like the part like you had to go
to the I could still go I just don't the
Happy Madison Christmas Stephen Dorff is
there yeah you know all the [ __ ] hunt
David Spade is there like that's like
Hollywood food you go and it's cool it's
like a mall yeah and there's bowling
there's ice skating there's like in
every executive it's there you feel like
check-in like you're going to a [ __ ]
Lakers game like it's a big deal and the
fact that you
to rowdy to go back no I was around I
some [ __ ] went down then obviously since
I was five feet from it I took the blame
like right away like I was the one that
was involved like some happening
misunderstanding with two broads over
bowling shoes you know me I don't know I
took my wife I was there with my wife
weird so it was just really weird I
didn't get along with one of his
executive producers mm-hmm like I got
along with Michael ben-ari I know I
loved Adam Adam was my dog one of the
producers he had was not his producing
partner anymore me and him and had beef
you know so it was rough on a longer
shot but he put me in a couple more
movies after that always giving me nice
respect I've always been a great guy I
see him maybe once every 18 weren't at
the store he stops he gives me a hug I
don't ask I loved his special Mike to
write a letter bro it's not bad yeah i
watch this finally first 20 minutes but
he's all down with god I was just like
you know it was also just like I'm
dancing I'm laughing I'm like oh they
gave 15 million - so I'd be up there
dancing in a [ __ ] drum I'd be doing
everything and I don't and look and my
next special is definitely very like
there's a lot of heavy [ __ ] in it
whatever but it's like I think the days
of just like innocent comedy are
starting to kind of you know now it's
like you got to make a statement you
have to make a political statement you
have to like move the needle on social
progress you can't say this okay it was
just kind of nice to watch a special
that was just like we're here to laugh
I'm not here to lecture you I'm not here
to yell at you like I'm just here to
make you laugh and enjoy it was I was
dazzled it was like I felt like a kid
watching it you know the last time you
won Rogan was one three months and
before that was it like every six for
six months wait because I don't know if
it was his last time the one before you
spoke about the transition getting made
in your life
you had gone through a big transition
know if you went to therapy you all you
were talking about how when you went to
a place and somebody gave you a gift you
would have a hard time like why is this
person giving me a camera saving tries
me crazy
get it drives me crazy if
you give me a gift if I even let you
give it to me I have to wait till you
leave to even open it it drives me crazy
and then you realize that you offer - my
play we got three great posters somebody
sent to read great Clint Eastwood
posters Italian [ __ ] that's like one
like that I already got me that was you
know that's my favorite movie of all
time but this guy sent me Italian
versions of it it's for real they're
only getting framed in New York my
brother framing what we told him about
the gifts Ghengis when I watched that
podcast I was going through a lot right
before the Netflix special something
happened to me I don't know what it was
something happened to my standup I had
spoken to you one day and we spoke about
flappers now we couldn't do material at
the store and I was kind of I was happy
with my Netflix set but I wasn't that
something was missing and then the day
uh it just it didn't matter it all went
away like two weeks after I shot the
Netflix special and that's when you were
on the podcast and I watch it you were
going through and it was like I was
going through the same [ __ ] you were
going through I was going through the
because it is the gift of acceptability
accepting what's going on mm-hmm
sometimes just moved quick yeah and you
have mine don't have the process the
time you know one minute you're at the
store next minute even a lot we
Christopher Walken at CBS yeah
if somebody's asking you what do you
want mint tea or lemon mint tea from
Europe with a lime of twist and your
life thank you talking about I was at
the store last night known about eating
some [ __ ] midgets [ __ ] no I'm here
with Christopher Walken and you asked me
if I want they you know I'm saying you
know how much ever do you have any idea
from clips of a shift that is that
people and I'm not putting anybody down
but it's not like one day you're on you
work on a construction job the next day
Trump comes on your job yeah it's it's
it's all a triumph for somebody who
you're a fan of so for us sometimes this
moves just a little bit too fast and we
gotta slow it down thank God thank God
that you yourself and your higher power
what were your depending on puts the
brakes on one day when you're on the 101
and you're about to get off Laurel
Canyon and do miles in like why is that
- Laurel Canyon exits but there's really
just one or two miles you I wasn't
accepting things I wasn't accepting the
Netflix special I couldn't accept why I
was selling out shows I couldn't accept
the fact that Whitney wants to take a
[ __ ] picture of me at the Comedy
Store
I can't effect I can't accept the fact
that this guy not Lee I'm saying this
guy just came up to me had tears in his
eyes and said because of me and Whitney
talking about her dad and my mom or my
mom and her mom be now he's dead life
changed you can't wrap your arms around
that [ __ ] when some of the ugliness is
ain't meant that conversation you
wouldn't he had [ __ ] made me go to
Halle not like I died I wrote a book in
it I talked about my struggles with
addiction and eating disorders and
little bells stuff and yeah now I have
people coming up to me like I read your
book and now I'm in a thing and I got
out of an abusive relationship and I
just didn't like it's and I know it's
hard because it's so much pressure in
that moment because they need so much
from you or they need some kind of
reaction from you and you don't want to
reject them or ice them or be awkward or
go like said about example of not being
able to receive so it's so hard when it
happens in airports it happens it
happens a lot like thank you so much I
got you know and I don't know what to
say and I feel this shame come up and
this embarrassment and this like I don't
deserve this I can't that's it the same
but if you really knew me and it's
imposter syndrome of like if you really
knew me if you really knew me that I ate
honey I'm sure midgets
Bassel you wouldn't you wouldn't be
taking this picture so and then I want
to go don't know I'm actually a phony
I'm a fraud I'm so full of [ __ ] I still
do horrible things like and then I feel
like I'm being dishonest or something I
get really confused by that dynamic you
know I think you know I've just been a
dirtbag for so long it's like when you
when people see you is something you're
like put your
pedestal you like no no I don't belong
here I don't belong here will you throw
me back in coach don't watch bill burn
what do you bother me yeah what yet go
watch some passion that's real comedy
you bother and then you make them feel
bad for liking you like you away this
moment from me by self-deprecating and
having low self-esteem and then I
realize like okay this isn't about you
like you can be of service to this
person in this moment and just let them
have their experience with you and just
kind of do nothing because it'll project
onto you whatever they need just shut
your mouth say thank you
don't argue with them don't tell them
all the reasons that you don't deserve
their attention don't self deprecate
take the photo be gracious and walk away
it's it's been really difficult for me
to receiving compliments well I gotta
ask you one last thing I know you got
[ __ ] to do and [ __ ] to see they
be able to tell you I have a psychic I
mean how the [ __ ] did you know to
abandon ship on Roseanne a week before
the ship went down and if I can't ask
you that you can ask whatever you want
just for legal ramen I don't know
there's no legal anything um no I
I mean it's weird because I I guess
there are lots of tweets before I just
didn't see them like even when you know
like how did the whole Roseanne thing
come about I was gonna say I don't want
to look but like no when after the
election happened um this kind of full
circle to what we were first talking
about like when the election happens it
was just you know I think every
regardless of who you voted for
regardless of who you support it was
like whoa like this is crazy and my
family started breaking apart and I bear
little family left it was like my aunt
wouldn't talk to my eye and I mean and
everyone's fighting and I just like this
is [ __ ] crazy Facebook just turn into
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you damn like something
just changed something shifted and I've
always been a little bit disgruntled
about Hollywood in general and feeling
like an outsider in Hollywood very like
I want to write about like you know
middle class people like working-class
problems I want to write about paying
bills and everyone was like you should
write about her getting married and it
was like who wants to see that you know
like I just never understood that sort
of elite storytelling because I grew up
poor and that's just not my experience
and I can
right what I know and I always love rose
am it's always a really big fan and
Michelle Obama had done a conference
call and she had a bunch of show runners
and producers on it I'm jumping around I
know but she said that the metrics were
in and who like Obama or not doesn't
matter the point the point is the method
that this research just happened to have
come through her that is objective which
is that they can now link the passage of
marriage equality to the show Will &
Grace so for people that might not have
gay friends or know gay couples like
they could you know have that show in
their living room you know once a week
and they felt more tolerant and more
accepting that you know gay people have
problems just like us and they fail and
they have heartbreak and they have you
know triumphs and you know so that was
helpful and she was like you know so
please in your TV shows just keep that
in mind that like television can move
the needle on social change and
awareness and I was like oh that was
that's interesting because I thought
that we were just a bunch of like
frivolous narcissistic selfish people
like you know look at our TV shows you
know I always kind of felt like guilty
about my job choice and indulgent or
something so god that's cool like that's
what Roseanne did you know and because I
mean Roseanne dealt with some heavy [ __ ]
I mean there was an episode where DJ
wouldn't kiss the black girls right
tremendous tremendous and then Jackie
the domestic violence episode which I
mean this isn't a sitcom you know Jackie
got knocked in the face you know so
there was a lot a really amazing and I
just John Goodman is you know were you a
fan of the show you know okay huge did
you ever see the Larry King interview
with her with her back then no about
four years ago I don't think so that's
all what she said that see you were to
watch that interview I would have known
yeah she said that a hoper kidnapped her
and put sensors in her brain to try to
steal her ideas but she said something
wow that was so [ __ ] brilliant in
that whole conversation that I'll never
forget and it gives me even more pride
of being an r-rated comic I'm never [ __ ]
he asked her about the show in 87 he
goes why did you troll um be ABC
executives out of your Christmas party
lady said you heard about that hey
that's the Moschino I'll tell you why
cuz she goes there no [ __ ] she goes on
the [ __ ] comic and when your atomic
you direct you produce your right you do
it all yeah they wanted the number one
show I gave them the number one show we
beat [ __ ] Cosby and his perverts over
there and now they want to come and take
all the credit
that's nice room all the [ __ ] out after
they said don't do the black kid show
don't do that all the most genius stuff
I respected her all the way you know I'm
still not mad at her today you know she
started in Denver I started yeah he's
from Denver that's why she was blowing
up that's like I still never mean the
honor because of the Roseann success
comedy in Denver is now a boom you could
take classes and that's what I went to
class is 91 I start right off the heels
of Roseanne [ __ ] killings blown just
exploded and look and yeah so I didn't
know and I knew about you know she
admitted to having some psychological
limitations I have a lot of that in my
life and my family like I'm never gonna
judge someone for that or make fun of
them for that or not work with them
because of that and you know I heard she
was like you know a Bernie supporter and
then voted for this and I was just
fascinated but you know without having
any judgments like I think you should be
able to work with somebody even if you
don't necessarily agree with them yeah
you know it was just sort of like yeah
it was just like [ __ ] this is gonna get
rebooted at a time when all of this is
happening in the zeitgeist like I can be
a part of something that people are
gonna actually watch because most people
don't watch [ __ ] let's just be honest
like a lot of TV shows like like you
know there's there's word that in this
echo chamber where we watch our shows
and we're all pat ourselves on the back
look how great these shows are but like
a lot of the shows are the that are
doing really well are these multi cams
that people in Hollywood kind of make
fun of and are really sort of glib about
like oh the CBS multi cams and da it's
like all right well those are things
people are watching so this is a
democracy why aren't we listening to the
people that we're entertaining you know
it's like being a comic and you're
bombing but just like moving forward
with a shitty bit that's not even
working you know it was [ __ ] Joe yeah
let's talk about yeah
the rows of pond it's like what the fart
like so for me I'm wired as a comic to
just go like what do people actually
want and like let's go from there and
Multi cams you know we're always um such
a big part of my life so this whole like
like people not liking multi camps makes
no sense they're all the shows that we
grew up on and are still our favorite
we're still watching Seinfeld and
Friends they're still like the
highest-rated shows like no one's making
new good ones for it and that's what
people want anyway so I thought you know
what I can't say no to this opportunity
I mean she's one of my comedy heroes
this was one of the best Multi cams I
want to learn how to make good multicam
cuz it's really hard it's a science to
not make it look corny and make the
lighting suck like it always felt like a
play you know there were drama moments
there was lots of silence you notice
with the shows now like Joe everything
someone says is a joke they would go a
minute without a joke you know they were
eating they had cereal boxes out it was
messy the set does not you know you look
at sitcoms now it always looks like a
fake sort of like store window there was
like the Wardrobe they would wear the
same clothes a couple times they really
honor the reality of being working-class
and a lot of shows even if there's a
show about a poor person they're wearing
fancy clothes and it's just as doesn't
feel like integrity and so I just was
just fascinated by how they did that
everything from the set design to the
acting to the writing to the camera
worked the lighting and casting and
wardrobe so I just felt like I had this
is how I'm gonna make sense of this
moment in time and you know got Wanda
Sykes in Noir McDonald and Morgan Murphy
and all these incredible writers and
then we paired up with a lot of the
writers that were on the original
Roseanne you know Bruce Helford and and
Bruce Rasmussen and Dave Kaplan all
these guys and and I just I wanted to
expose myself to point of views that I
didn't hold or necessarily even agree
with or understand because then you're
not growing what are you doing if you're
just hanging out with only people that
agree with you you just get stupid you
don't mean and you get narcissistic and
you're I was just like felt like I was
in my echo chamber my version of doing
it
a couple years ago is I just like went
to Vietnam for two weeks you know I just
didn't like try to get out of my sort of
little bubble and on and again I was a
fan of Roseanne I didn't follow her on
Twitter I didn't find out till later
that there were lots of old tweets in
look you know again like if
you're being crazy and not hurting
anybody like that's none of my business
I'm not gonna hold you accountable for
that I didn't know about the drama and
the Nazi photo and the Hillary Pizza
Parlor like I just didn't know about it
cuz I just didn't follow her and then I
started to become very clear that the
tweeting was a big problem and I had
been trying to convince everyone to shut
that down for a while to no avail but I
also didn't want to silence a comment
you know it's not my job to tell you to
stop saying whatever you believe so I
was in this kind of really tricky
situation where it's like oh I'm gonna
tell one of the best performers in the
world to stop like having her creative
outlet like that's arrogant so it just
became clear that it was just going to
continue to be really hard and
unnecessarily controversial and I just
wanted to slowly kind of back out of the
burning building and then well it was it
was actually like a couple months you
know it leaked to the press because I
don't want to make a drama out of it I
didn't want to be a news story that I
was leaving because I was really only
gonna do one season anyway I just wanted
to do the one season back because I was
just doing other things in touring and
stuff but um I'm still really glad I did
it I mean it's heartbreaking what
happened um and frustrating and I was
really angry for a while I'm not angry
anymore I'm kind of just more like sad
well I'm gonna tell you something this
is what a lot of people understand I got
here in 97 and by 97 there were two
people they wanted to kill Roseanne was
one of them and grace under fire grace
and the fire pissed them off so much
they cancelled that [ __ ] with 98
episodes they won't even look on the
syndication because the abuse ABC was
getting from those women I was in shock
when they rehired Roseanne because I was
here to hear all those stories you know
was crazy I saw it she could not have
been more lovely to every Moshi's lovely
I know is when you tell a comic you
don't think that one moment with the
Amigo she got that every day all day on
her material imagine someone coming to
you oh you tell a story that's been
killing for two years and they're like
ah can you do it this way and you're
like get the [ __ ] out of here this is
already killing
like it's this is proven to be good what
the [ __ ] do you know some executive
giving you notes on what's funny you
know so she had to endure that for so
long and yes she was struggling with
addiction you know there were all sorts
of things going on but I was never
deterred by that reputation you know cuz
I had a modicum of a moment where I had
my own show and I've tasted like you
know a 1/100 of what she had to deal
with and I was like I get it what's in
the future for you beautiful must I
break a [ __ ] hearts on a daily
basis [ __ ]
I'm still breaking on trying to get
funny enough to follow you at the
comedies yet that's the least of your
worries
you got a boyfriend I have a fiance
thank you not weird
no you don't ask I don't get it you
never see me do stand-up how are you
been with him it's almost two years hey
you never want to see you do something
never seen me do it live man that's his
best bet he's not funny I don't want him
to wagon I do I do
you ready to get married I think I am
like I'm trying not to overthink it kids
I froze my eggs I think maybe you know I
didn't ever want kids and then my dad
died and I was like oh I want something
that looks like him in some way you know
like the concept of like procreating
became sort of more of a like calling
that I never felt before I was like I
have dogs I'd horse it like I will just
do that I'll adopt a kid let needs a
home you know like I always thought I
would adopt a kid but then after my dad
passed away I had this weird like well I
want to adopt yeah that's a good idea
around a great family I wish you nothing
but luck tonight when I talk to people
about yeah go you know what I would love
to show Whitney Cummings my balls
because you probably get up told me to
put mine away and put yours on the table
and they'd be bigger than mine so you
did say that's me want they give me so
much strength you have you have all the
respect and admiration for me I love you
congratulations on your wedding or
whatever you do whatever you want to
come back and talk [ __ ] about y'all and
I wish that if this goes further with
Fox I get you involved with this I'll do
anything
and I'm gonna be aggressive about it too
like the Louisa please let me come over
CIA yeah no but I'll just come to the
table reads and I'll just you know any
insight rush even if it's just to say
especially after what he told me too
that you know when I went through yeah
you really know what else yes and the
network note that I love there you know
my mom used to do two pinatas
one for the kids at three o'clock and
one for the adults and the adult ones
she would have fill up with a little
cocaine and the kids would be gone the
adults are pulled up in Y not at mommy
we go going there and get the aluminum
foils for mommy I'm back from my mother
here's your cold open that's your
flashbacks wipe your nose except these
are all things that only you love this
this fall on Fox wipe your nose wipe you
though yeah I probably also they're all
there I'm doing a million [ __ ] dates
but I'm shooting my special DC March
twenty something and it's Whitney
Cummings
yes you never know because Gmail done
that some people are like how hilarious
Lindsay no yeah make it your [ __ ]
name
get your domain go to uh Whitney
companies comm check up her upcoming
dates she's one of the good she's one of
the ladies in the comedy store who
destroys my moves in the lineup with
[ __ ] killers on a Tuesday night most
women would stay home and watch oranges
are no purple she comes down to the [ __ ]
people up so in my world you get all the
respect that you I I'm ultimately what's
he saying what's the end of what's
grease I'm not a fool turn around and
wait for you
you're a good thing ultimi what was it
son oh I just know grace lightning or Oh
[ __ ] rock that's me I feel like this
wasn't feel like I'm never funny on
podcast and then I I'm gonna beat myself
up in the car for like two hours I don't
know you know I should've been funnier I
start telling a funny story I love you
thank you very much would be coming
Scott calm she's family
give her whatever she wants yeah and
that's it I want to thank Whitney I want
to thank the [ __ ]
his mom's coming to town he's all happy
see you guys are having a great time
next week and I'm your uncle Joey I love
your [ __ ] we won't be around
next week you'll have a rough week
without me because I'm gonna be in New
York City with my family but we might do
something maybe Thursday just to keep
you on ice if me and Lea boarded we sick
of his mom oh absolutely yeah I'm trying
to get there to start a podcast oh good
I'll do it it's just a mom advice one
yeah yeah it's actually a really good
idea to tell her that yeah she's nervous
I don't think that's good don't forget
for you after Christmas [ __ ]
where are you that week or your
important after quit first week I'm in
Raleigh there's a new club in Raleigh
good nope
I think it's an improv oh sorry I should
really know my venues but anyway if you
not got nothing to do after Christmas of
27 28 29 I'm up in Oxnard at levity live
and that's it that's that all right I
want to thank Whitney Cummings I want to
thank the flying Jew aka the
[ __ ]
aka the Momo savant aka Lee and out of
space aka my little brother for helping
him out and I want to thank you guys for
always having our backs and supporting
this like I said if he came from ahoy
you guys saw a great show Lee did great
Eric Rocha did great me I don't know
what the [ __ ] I do I get up and I do
what I do but I want to thank you guys
for all your support go up to here but
hold on one second I want to talk about
a couple things first of all Robin Hood
is an investment at that lets you buy
and sell stocks ETFs is options cryptos
or commission free it's a non
intimidating way for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence simple and
intuitive intuitive it's a clear design
with data presented and an easy to
digest way all right number one and this
is how this is how easy this is
there's no Commission fees other
brokerages charge up to $10 for every
trade but
Robin Hood does not charge Commission
fees trade stocks or keep all your
profits it's easily understand charts
and market data place a trade and just
for taps on your smartphone just for
taps Robin Hood web platform also lets
you view stock collections the 100 most
popular sectors like entertainment and
social media and curated categories like
female CEOs and analysts ratings by hold
and sell for every stock listen you
learn by doing you learn how to invest
as you build your portfolio you discover
new stocks and track favorite companies
with personal ID news feeds custom
notifications for price movements so
you'll never miss the right time to
invest are you getting me or what this
is what Robin Hood is doing and I'll
tell you what else they're gonna do as
far as the kickoff this is how you kick
off a year Robin Hood has given the
church family a free stock like Apple
for the sprint to help build your
portfolio Grad is free sign up a church
dot Robin Hood com that's church dot
Robin Hood dot-com when you think the
perfect gift you probably don't think of
an electric toothbrush but the quip
electric toothbrush is one of the most
gift guide and gifts of the season
here's why it's perfect for everyone
with a month and it's something they'll
use twice everyday listen me and my wife
we love it you plug it in it takes one
charge every I don't know what the
thirty days or something like that don't
matter
especially if you're a traveler equip is
the way to go why as sonic vibrations
gentle enough on your sensitive gums and
a built-in timer with guiding pulses to
remind you when to switch sides
quick makes holiday travels clean and
easy with the multi use cover that
monster mirrors and on monster slide
over the bristles for on-the-go brushing
grip doesn't require a chunky charger it
runs on three months on one charge three
months on one charge equip is to get
that keeps refreshing with brush heads
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for five hours now you can even give
prepaid refills
for the year to make sure you're never
using old worn-out and effective
bristles quip is also one of the first
electric toothbrushes accepted by the
American Dental Association and has
thousands of verified five-star reviews
okay this is why I love equipped and
this is why I might think equip is a
good gift for you clip has been great to
be in my wife and with over five
thousand verified star reviews you can't
go wrong
quit on the outside it looks like a big
ticket tech gift but with the stocking
stuffer price starting at twenty five
hours and if you go to get quick calm
slash Joey right now you'll get your
first refill pack for free with a quip
electric toothbrush but you don't have
to tell your gifty that all right Merry
Christmas
spread some cheer this year go to get
quick calm slash Joey right now and
start to clean your mouth and give the
gift a clean mouth so from now on you
don't get shot in the face with bad
breath you know I'm saying cause bad
breath will kill you too I also want to
thank I want to talk to you be but some
it's that time of year enough is enough
for the last thirty years your [ __ ]
been stinking like a billy goat and this
can't continue
cuz you're a filthy [ __ ] a I got my
issues - my ass is no [ __ ] Wonderland
either that's why I got a tushy calm let
me tell you some hello - she is the
number one provider affordable bidets
takes you ten minutes of per line you
can have hot or cold water as far as a
60-day guarantee you can wipe your ass
with it because it's helped my stinky
ass [ __ ] three years you understand
me
so if it could hold my 300 pounds stinky
[ __ ] muff for a debt then imagine
what the wonders it'll do for you a nice
simple [ __ ] you're a nice guy
you eat [ __ ] kale you take a hundred
products but anyway how about her she is
one of the best gifts you could give
somebody because they start at 69
[ __ ] dollars listen $69 listen 69
dollars they come in all colors they got
a little Turkish towel so you drive you
a little muffler after that you put a
little top and powder in your ass and
later on you stay naked in your fart the
pilot goes out of your ass I used to do
it all the time in the fourth grade
that's why they almost threw me out of
Catholic school but anyway go - hello -
she calm right now
take a look at the fine selection of the
portable bidet you see something you
like pressing muffler and get 10% off
your that's how we're rolling tonight
again I want to thank my girl Whitney
Cummings I want to thank Lee and I want
to thank you guys for being family and
for having my back ain't [ __ ] but with
you guys I got a [ __ ] shot I'll
see you guys next week or in 10 days but
I'll pop up I'll be on the periscope
I'll be I'll be around don't worry about
nothing I'm like Tony Bennett I want to
be around all right I love you guys stay
black have a great week
get that [ __ ] melee